les nouveaux locaux de l'école de
musique tellancourt sonne enfants les
670 élèves ont pu passer de la maison
cartier partager avec d'autres
associations à ce bâtiment dont
l'acoustique des salles a été
particulièrement étudié la halle et le
bâtiment est 100% dédié à eux chaque
salle est adapté le matériel est en
place dès qu'ils arrivent pas de perte
de temps
tout de suite on peut s'exprimer ils
peuvent repartir et ainsi de suite
d'un point de vue architectural les
briques de l'ancien centre oecuménique
ont été conservés il retrouve l'esprit
du temps par son éclairage
c'est là où vous voyez toutes les
parties ajourées qui dans la journée
laisse entrer la lumière naturelle dans
le bâtiment et qui la nuit va permettre
d' illuminé le bâtiment par l'éclairage
interne du violon classique aux
instruments numériques très sale
différentes vont permettre des pratiques
variées pour les représentations un
auditorium a également été installée la
ville d'elancourt tu vas te faire
grandir cette école de musique qui
propose déjà l'apprentissage de 24
instruments donc on essaiera bien
d'autres dans les années à venir de
procéder à une augmentation de la
fréquentation
ce qui va de pair avec un autre projet
que nous avons qui est la
municipalisation d'écoles de musique
cette nouvelle école de musique rentrer
dans une stratégie globale de
redynamiser le quartier 17 mars entre
activités commerciales et culturelles
[Musique]